the first trailer for ant-man and the
wasp just dropped revealing a ton of
cool new characters and details we can
look forward to seeing in the ant-man
sequel you peek a weeble of us it's Jan
here and today I'm breaking down the new
trailer and explaining some Easter eggs
and wicked details and other stuff you
might have missed if you're new to my
channel I do regular comic book movie
videos and to celebrate the first
ant-man and the wasp trailer I'm kicking
off a new superhero giveaway for all my
subscribers and I've got full details on
that giveaway later in this video
ant-man and the wasp begins in the
aftermath of Captain America Civil War
at the end of Civil War cap broke out
ant-man and the other Avengers who were
locked up in the raft prison and in
ant-man and the wasp it looks like we'll
find that the authorities have caught up
with Scott Lang putting him under house
arrest it's pretty clear there that once
hope Van Dyne and Hank Pym make contact
with him again Scott isn't going to be
at home very long hope and hanker on the
run themselves in fact hope blames that
on Scott Civil War antics which might
mean that their research has come under
scrutiny and suggests why hank is using
Pym particles to shrink down his
building into a portable piece of
luggage the new vision that Hank and
hope contact Scott about is their plan
to bring back Hanks wife Janet Van Dyne
from the quantum realm in the first
ant-man movie Hank explained that during
their mission to deactivate a bomb Janet
who was the original wasp went subatomic
when she deactivated her regulator to
get inside the bomb though Scott went
subatomic at the end of that movie he
managed to return which is why Hank has
been researching how they can go to the
quantum realm to bring back Janet who in
this movie will be played by Michelle
Pfeiffer and we might just have our
first glimpse of their journey into the
quantum realm in this shot the creatures
around them look a lot like tardigrades
aka water burrs which are real
eight-legged micro animals and are about
half a millimeter or 0 points there are
two inches long at their full size we
don't know yet if this is the quantum
realm itself or just an interim stage
where hope and Scott shrink down their
new craft until they reach the subatomic
level the quantum realm has appeared
briefly twice before in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe first at the end of
man and then again momentarily and dr.
strange when the ancient one sent
Stephen strange through the multiverse
when he met her at come on tosh
obviously we've got to talk about hope
Van Dyne is the wasp the trailer
showcases an awesome power set for the
new hero in addition to ant-man
shrinking power she can fly and shoot
power blasts the blasters are a nice
touch because in the comics hank pym
gave the wasp wrist devices which could
produce electrified blasts that she
named wasp stings and I just love how
wasp shows he's a literal Blade Runner
in this very cool slow-mo shot of her
running down the side of these knives
which echoes ant-man's gun-running
antics in his first movie and when the
wasp throws the Hello Kitty PEZ
dispenser it's another cool call back to
the first movie when ant-man turned to
Thomas the Tank Engine toy giant-sized
on top of that the Hello Kitty nod also
adds a little Deadpool vibe especially
given that the popular Marvel character
could be joining the MCU if Disney's
deal with Fox goes ahead now you'll need
to look very carefully but we do get a
super brief look at the villainous
characters Sonny Burge played by Walton
Goggins and he appears to have stolen
PIMs miniaturized building in the comics
sonny birch is a chairman of cross
technologies and in ant-man and the wasp
it seems he could be trying to steal Pym
secrets to either get revenge for or
take advantage of the demise of PIMs
former protege Darren cross in the first
movie and that looks like the reason we
get the return of giant man who we see
towering over the boat presumably to
recover the stolen property the trailer
also gives us a quick tease of the new
villain ghost who's played by Hannah
John caiman in the comics ghost is
actually male and as an elite hacker who
can make himself invisible and phase
through objects and that might be what's
going on here where we can see an arm
flickering and phasing in and out of
view the comic book version of ghost
uses his abilities to attack and destroy
corporations and I wonder whether the MC
use ghost could be connected to the
villainous Hydra you might recall that
Hydra agents attended Darren crosses
presentation in the ant-man movie and
one of the attendees Mitchell Carson
managed to escape with
vial of Pym particles before the
building exploded
so perhaps ghosts could be working for
Hydra and it's also quite possible that
she's working together with Walton
Goggins characters sunny birch the
trailer also gives us a quick peek at
Laurence Fishburne who's playing doctor
bill Foster aka Goliath in the comics
dr. Foster is a scientist who worked for
both Tony Stark and Hank Pym Foster
became familiar with how Pym particles
worked and experimented on himself
creating his giant-sized alter-ego
Goliath
he's traditionally a good guy so it's
quite likely he'll team up with Scott
Hope and Hank however while the trailer
doesn't reveal a lot about dr. Foster
the way it's edited may imply he could
be connected with ghosts or the bad guys
at some point by the way appropriately
enough the music and the trailer is
called ants invasion and is by the
British band Adam and the ants so did
the ant-man and the wasp trailer get you
hyped for the movie and were there any
other cool details or Easter eggs you
spotted make sure you leave a comment
below about the trailer and subscribe
for a chance to win a cool ant-man Funko
pop if you enjoyed this remember to like
and share and do hit that notification
bell to get all my new videos you can
also check out more of my Marvel and
other superhero videos by tapping the
screen here thanks for watching and see
you next time
yippie Chi we be lovers